we are here on all-star Tuesday Major
League Baseball all-star Tuesday
we're in Nationals Park tonight of we we
hope to see is an exciting and event as
we saw last night in the home run derby
I'm not just saying that because the
manager is sitting right here to my left
Al Leiter of MLB Network will be joining
me here in a moment we've already had
two not one but two Hall of Fame
catchers Johnny Bench and Pudge
Rodriguez here in studio but I want to
turn to my left right here to leadoff
our number three as I said day number
two of the rich Eisen show here in
Washington DC home of the Major League
Baseball all-star game the Commissioner
of Major League Baseball Rob Manfred
kind enough to be here on the program
once again get to see her Commissioner
good to be here you gotta be here now
before we get into a business of
baseball you I'd love to give you the
the platform for my man Mike del to fo
over there wearing the price headgear
from last night you had a couple of
things you wanted to point out to him
when you got out here on the set well
you know III said in the greenroom and I
was watching the show and in the
half-hour I saw oh he was 1 & 2 was my
evaluation he gets a point a win okay
for not taking his shirt off I think
that was a W it's W for everyone
involved greatly agree yeah there was
the the shirtless photograph of Dan
Patrick and Chris and the rest of the
crew but it's okay
I'll take that one unfortunately I had
to hang two L's on him one was the NFL
shirt baseball merchandise available
here in DC but I'm gonna send them some
free one yeah you're talking his
language and then the last one I I don't
want to dwell on I did see the homerun
Derby segment hmm gotta work on this way
yeah and there's some work that he's
done there Walt her eniac videos we can
get for here you missed anything you
could see it on our app and and it's
great to see you here what was it like
for you seeing that homerun Derby
well you know it was really funny your
plan and you know I think one of the
keys for us in the Derby it's great to
have a hometown player who's you know
deep into the Derby that's a great thing
we always
oh poor because it's great for the fans
and and that's what the Derby is about
being good for the fans right but I'll
tell you when he got down to 115 one
minute I thought oh man this script is
worked perfect till now but he's just
not going to get there and man that last
minute or so was something special
really something special
yes hey let me get the exact numbers
here he hit six home runs in the final
twenty nine seconds nine home runs in
the final 47 seconds the whole place lit
up I mean that was something else art do
you guys in the front office of baseball
reach out personally to some of these so
called if you will stars of the game to
say would you participate we'd actively
do that we do personally we work through
the club's you know the closest
relationship you always got to remember
us between the club and the player and
the Nationals were phenomenal in terms
of working with Brice it started over a
year ago he started saying he was gonna
do it and it's really important I guess
the second thing I'd say about last
night you know we went to the new format
with the clock and yeah and everything
in 2015 and you I've talked about that
before but since that new format we've
kept track of how many home runs got hit
there were 18 more last night than have
ever been hit in a home run derby which
talks about the quality of the
performances all the way up and down I
mean the guys that agreed to participate
were enthusiastic they put on a great
show and we had the most ever home runs
in rounds two and three and you know it
does get harder I mean you do get right
exhausted just from so all the swinging
so it's a great show all the way around
hats off to all the players who
participate well I mean the in terms of
the name players I mean obviously you if
you want you want to get as many people
out and that's not I understand that
that is disrespectful to the guys who do
put their bats in their hands right and
compete but I mean if you want to get
some of these all-stars that are playing
tonight don't you want them in obviously
we'd like to have the highest profile
players that we could have but you know
you also want guys who are gonna put on
a good show and there's two elements to
that there's particular kinds of hitters
and I think schwöre burr would be an
example who are inclined you know
they're gonna put on a good show and
then the other thing that's really in
interesting I think players who really
want to be in the event and you know it
says something about athletics generally
I think just tend to really perform III
think Hoskins is a great example of it
he wanted to be in the event and you
know he put on a good show
Commissioner Rob Manfred here and I did
notice last night Commissioner because
you know I try to have a keen interest
in everything the young men and women
who were shagging flyballs they did
appear to be shifted they were all
bunched up you have one side of the
field well it seems to be the trend
right yes we're 6,000 pitches this year
you'll see the shift that's your number
that's what I want to I kind of want to
hit this thing because this is a
windmill I'm trying to tilt at right
here it drives me nuts I think it takes
offense out of the game and if I may
just remain on my soapbox a little bit
longer I think it is added two more
strikeouts that I think you're a lot of
guys are trying to hit it over the shift
and it takes offense out of the game I'm
wondering if there is any appetite from
your position to put a rule out there to
get rid of the shift well you know I
promised Pat Courtney yes PR director
that I would not get into individual
rule changes today but let me say this
and I do think it's important I I think
there's a consensus a growing consensus
among ownership that we need to have a
serious dialogue with the players that
goes beyond pace of play and talks about
the way the game is being played on the
field and I think that there's been a
lot of I call it organic change you know
changes that have been driven by general
managers and managers trying to win to
one or two more games it has changed the
way the game looks on the field and I
think we need to have a conversation
about whether or not it's time to
intercede and manage that change a
little more aggressively shifts are at
the top of a lot of people's lists yeah
it's certainly at the top mine I asked
AJ Hinch who is obviously somebody who
uses it quite a bit and is an analytics
centric although a guy who just you know
manages from the gut is
well that's why he's obviously so
sinister is the world series defending
champion manager if he would have an
appetite for a rule and he said
absolutely not
like he was telling me to basically go
pound sand on this idea yeah I think
that the counter-argument is that we've
never gotten into defensive positioning
and you know it would be a big change
and I think the other concern that
people have is how predictable will the
outcome be so let's start with chefs
right sure
so when shift started to become more and
more prevalent
everybody said don't worry about it you
know the the these are the greatest
athletes in the world they're going to
adjust and everybody assumed the
adjustment would be we'll hit it the
other way right and the open part of the
field well they were right on 1 & 2 they
are the greatest athletes in the world
they did adjust
unfortunately the adjustment they made
is I'm going to try to hit everything up
over the top right I'm gonna hit over
the shift and why why because analytics
told them that the value of getting that
home warrant run in terms of producing a
win is higher than hitting to the
opposite field so when you start making
these rules you have to really think
through carefully you want to manage the
game you want to keep the game
entertaining for the fans but you really
have to think through carefully what the
outcome is really gonna be and whether
you're gonna get the outcome you want
well I don't get at the risk of
potentially upsetting our friend Pat
Courtney who is the best at what he does
in this business and I'm not just saying
that to butter you up because I'm about
to ask the Commissioner are the rules
related question but Tony Clark the MLB
players association chief said that
there is as he said gaining momentum for
designated hitter in the National League
would you agree with that assessment
that that's gaining momentum yeah you
know somebody read that quote to me we
did back to backs with the baseball
writers yeah you know my impression and
maybe this is me overestimating my
ability to make deals as always been
since 1987 that if I want to make a deal
with the MLBPA about spreading the D H
to the National
that deal was out there to be had so I
the fact that he's saying it's something
new surprises me a little bit but the
substantive position does not I think
players in general have been in favor of
the designated hitter so that that's not
a big surprise I I'm not sure in this
overall conversation whether the D H
should or shouldn't play a major role
the expansion of the D H I do know this
you know there is a brand of baseball
played in the National League that's
only played in the National League now
and to move the designated hit it over
there and make that brand of baseball
extinct I think we're gonna have to
think carefully about that make that
move it's a very traditionalist approach
right there yeah every once in a while
even I slip into it you gotta cater to
everybody but uh you know I'm not sure
it's the answer but I am committed to
the idea that we need to be having a
conversation including obviously the
people who play the game on the field
the players we've been after Tony to get
at this conversation and I don't think
about it as you know Rob Manfred out
there trying to change the game or the
owners are out there trying to change
the game I think about it as the games
changing is changing organically and are
we just gonna let that happen
or are we gonna manage the outcome in
order to preserve a game that we all
love that's a great game has great bones
and to enhance its entertainment value
for the fans well I'm gonna take a break
if you don't mind or stick around before
Leiter joins us a couple of items I do
want hit you know Tony Clark did have a
couple other things to say I want to
okay bounce off you I'm sure you've
heard what he had to say and we got a
couple of calls from our radio affiliate
in Portland interested in potentially
what's going on in that city along with
another pace of play question that I
have for you all right laying that all
out for commissioner Rob Manfred before
Al Leiter joins us here live on the Rich
Eisen show don't you dare move
welcome back to our show here I've we
just found out so commissioner Rob
Manfred you and I covered that we're at
the same first all-star game together -
my first one was was actually 89 at
Wrigley pet when was the last one in
Wrigley 89 89 that was my first one and
we're working what capacity it was an
outside lawyer and I they started going
then okay we represented baseball and
then at 97 in Colorado in Colorado I
decided to go in house that's where we
had conversations during that all-star
game that's when I decided that was my
first one I covered for ESPN and the the
most memorable one for me
that I brought up several times and I
will do so again because I brought it up
because Pedro was on yesterday and Pudge
was on today and that was the battery of
the first two innings for the American
League in the 1999 all-star game when my
job as the studio host for ESPN radio
coverage of the event was to be on a
field behind home plate and describe the
action of the all century team it's
unbelievable
oh my god it was a great moment great
baseball moment and you know for all the
hard work that went into the great
staging of the event the best part of it
was the players reaction it's had
Williams unbeliever players I mean just
a phenomenal moment cuz I'll say it
again I'll never forget how every player
converged on the pitcher's mound to get
a piece of Ted Williams if they could
yep and when they couldn't get to Ted I
look up and there's Randy Johnson
talking to Sandy Koufax
there's McGuire with Stan Musial I mean
I'm getting goosebumps just talking
about it and then the public address
announcer in Wrigley and Fenway
essentially told him to break it out we
got to start the game and I ask Pedro
about that yesterday and he's like
normally not getting out to the to the
bullpen to warm up for regular-season
you would have pissed him off so it
would really piss me off but instead he
just he wanted to be part of it like
kind of got upset him that he had to go
and I remember again I was there with my
wife who's a big you know from big New
England family and I turn on my you know
there's no way that this game is gonna
top that and then the first two innings
happen right where he struck out five of
the first six I mean only one the only
out that wasn't recorded by strikeout
was our second our guest Pudge Rodriguez
throwing Matt Williams out trying to
steal after that I turned I'm like okay
now this game will probably be in a
climactic and there was no I mean
there's nothing the homerun Derby to
where McGwire hit all those home runs
with a broken back didn't win in the
Derby it was but Ted Williams was there
that night now is part of the coverage
being Stuart Scott where we're splitting
up the the coverage that was
unbelievable yeah it was a great night I
Boston you know did a phenomenal job
excuse me with that all-star game and
the all-century team was a you know
great free game shelf really a great it
was it was I don't know how you can I
mean you can he can't do it obviously
there's only a century comes once every
hundred years but that was that was
really special yes Kevin Costner was the
emcee of it to me it was great
Rob Manfred here on the Rich Eisen show
a couple things coming from Rich Eisen
show radio affiliate in Portland rip
city radio 620 we got a bit a caller
calling yesterday he was watching a
minor league game and hit with his
family and all of a sudden they put a
sec run around second to start extra
innings he said he loved it he said he
absolutely loved it and that it added a
different level of intrigue how is that
how is that because I know that's a pace
of play right rule that you've been
putting in place it's a pilot program
that one is a rule it morphed on us a
little bit calm it was originally out
there as and you know came sort of out
of international baseball we used it in
the WBC and it was a mechanism to try to
complete games without going 18 innings
particularly in an event like the WBC
where he had pitch limitations right you
go 18 innings guys pitcher a lot you
know you're left with no pitchers it's
it's really a problem so we used it
there I saw it a couple times it was
very exciting and then there was some
talk about it and we backed away from it
a little bit became I said publicly I
didn't think it was a rule
we were gonna use at the major league
level and then it kind of got
resurrected it for use in the minor
leagues from with a push from the
development people right and you know
one of the important issues in
developing young players and pitchers in
particular is pitch counts you know in
those 18 inning games they messed the
you know you need people to pitch and it
gets pitchers out of whack they were
concerned that it might be causing
injuries and so they've gone to it in
the minor leagues and it's actually been
pretty positively received yeah guy
called and said it was great just that
the strategies changed and wait there's
this whole issue put somebody on second
are you gonna do you body or do you try
to get a base head it is interesting but
it isn't about moving it to the major
league level I'm still kind of an know
on that I think that you know there's a
certain when the games matter so much
and they don't have that you know
developmental purpose like you have in
the minor leagues I think the scale kind
of tips the other way and what about the
possibility of Major League Baseball in
Portland Oregon where does that stand
look we're lucky I mean I would say this
big picture we need to get Oakland and
Tampa Bay squared away before we talk
about expansion but I think we will get
them squared away I think we will
ultimately have a conversation about
expansion and we're blessed we have a
number of markets Portland Las Vegas
Nashville Charlotte that are viable
interested you know we're blessed and
that's not even to talk about you know
Montreal maybe someplace in Mexico all
of which would be possible and and
probably liable in terms of the
demographics of the markets so we're
lucky in that regard a lot of interest
in Major League Baseball's so in terms
of Portland you're viewing that as an
expansion city possibility not as we
never talk about cities as relocation
sure alternatives you know we've had a
great record of not really locating
franchises we have deep ties with the
communities where we play and I really
am hopeful that both Oakland and Tampa
Bay
figure it out where they are a couple
more minutes left here with Rob man for
the Commissioner of baseball Tony Clark
the union chief I'll read the direct
quote what the players saw last
offseason was that their free agent
rights were under attack attack on what
has been the bedrock of our system how
do you respond to that you know I think
that's inaccurate hyperbole to tell you
the truth I think if you look at the
market in retrospect and you look at the
performance of the players so far this
year what happened last year is our
clubs made really sound evaluations of
players what could reasonably be
expected from them in terms of
performance and the market operated
based on those judgments I think at the
end of the year you go back and look at
the statistics you're gonna decide that
the clubs did a pretty good job figuring
out how these available players were
gonna perform this year and how do you
view out of from a Commissioner's Office
a trade of someone like Manny Machado
which is rumored to be going down
tomorrow a top young player going from a
team here on the Mid Atlantic
potentially to a squad that made the
World Series last year how do you view
look I see it as a prudent business
decision on the part of the trading club
I think that the you know you got half a
season left you look at how the club's
performed you're probably not going to
win the World Series you're looking down
the barrel at free agency where you know
whether or not the player is going to be
there is his decision not yours and the
opportunity to give up three or four
months of performance and in return get
some high quality prospects that helps
you rebuild your team seems like it
makes sense okay before you go how would
you rate the pace of this interview
you're you are rarely boring rich I will
give you that okay really boring okay so
good pace yeah crisp yeah that's really
enjoyable it's always a pleasure to be
here I mean that okay so the quality of
the interview to pace and quality
outstanding I would say this segment
yes was a lot better than the shirts off
in the wiffle ball that we're in the
last things I think we improved the
content we did enjoy tonight all right I
will enjoy tonight I always appreciate
you making time it's great to see you
you got right there okay and Excel you
know just to be safe we'll send you a
couple thank you sir
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience